I'm joined Now by military analyst
retired Air Vice Marshal Sean Bell good
to see you Sean so what is the latest uh
on this huge explosion in Crimea and how
much damage has it done it was said
explosion in the port of Sebastopol home
of the Black Sea Fleet
um the uh the tanks the Russians claim
that four tanks were destroyed in fact
it looks like 10 vast storage facilities
for fuel oil and potentially up to 40
000 tons of fuel was destroyed today all
those happened yesterday morning today
it's all under control but the Russians
have claimed that ukrainians actually
did a drone strike which caused this and
they said it was mounted from Odessa
which is 250 kilometers away that's a
long way away for the drones to come
they've also claimed it was the mug in
five drones shown here these are 25
kilogram Warheads they're about five
meter wide three three meters long
um they've got a payload about 25
kilograms and they fly about 100 miles
an hour they only cost about ten
thousand pounds they're sourced in China
which seems a bit strange and the one
thing about this store which doesn't
quite add up is that the Russians have
been using these drones against the
ukrainians so we're not quite sure at
the moment whether this was actually the
Drone being used but that's what the
Russians have claimed now individually
these are very vulnerable
um but if you put them as a swarm of
drones and it looks like the ukrainians
have used 10 at a time so the Russians
managed air defenses managed to take out
some of them to manage to get through
and as you see it's the danger of having
these sorts of large quantity drones
that are relatively cheap and cheerful
individually not very effective
collectively can be very dangerous right
now it's interesting that Ukraine hasn't
claimed responsibility for this attack
you know one would assume that Russia
you know wouldn't be targeting their own
critical infrastructure either
nevertheless we are awaiting this spring
offensive could this be the beginning of
the opening Salvo one of the things
about the spring offensive much faunted
it won't start with a fan for a trumpets
and you know we're off it will almost
certainly be a phased approach and the
first phase will be ukrainians take
taking out lots of Russia's Logistics
support and things like the fuel about
where will that offensive happen three
main areas possibly up into the donbass
region the trumpets there's been Fierce
fighting going on there and actually be
very difficult to reverse that quickly
the Crimea the trouble is that's
massively reinforced it'll be very
difficult for Ukraine to make progress
there it's almost certainly it's going
to be this land bridge area here where
the main focus of the attacks like to be
if Ukraine is going to be successful in
these troops and Equipment troops 14 000
troops that have been trained in the UK
have now found their way back to Ukraine
they're ready to go and that's just the
UK lots of international Partners have
also done training and on the equipment
front native Secretary General said on
Thursday that 98 of the equipment that
had been promised to ukrainians has now
been delivered so that's 1500 armored
personnel carriers it's 230 tanks and
vast quantities of ammunition it does
look like Ukrainian preparations are
almost complete for that offensive right
and as we know Ukraine remains very very
tight-lipped about their operational
plans nevertheless as you say they are
they are preparing uh for this offensive
what do we know about how Russia's
preparing for this offensive the one
thing that they're not doing are
preparing at the moment is around back
moods because the fighting there they're
still intense fighting Russians still
grinding on we've been talking about
that for 11 months the Russians control
about 87 of back moot now but away from
that it's pretty evident Russia are very
nervous about what Ukraine's going to do
after all Russia has already lost 50
percent of the territory that it had
taken at one stage in this war if you
look at about in Crimea there's a vast
equipment storage area in Crimea over
the last few days that has been emptied
of armored personnel vehicles and tanks
completely empty and redeployed sap
reach a nuclear facility there's
emplacements actually the Russians are
putting sandbags in reinforcing their
really worrying because that's within
the nuclear series they're expecting to
fight there it's worth pointing out the
reactor is actually very well hardened
is fine so the Easter zap reach 1120
kilometers of trenches some of them
visible from space but also these
Dragon's Teeth which we haven't actually
seen since the second world war they're
one meter tall they are a pyramid in
function and they're made of concrete
they're just designed to slow down main
battle tanks and they're being used all
over the place
um this is old footage from last year
but it still shows the value I mean the
very fact that we've not been talking
about the poor in Ukraine for the last
week doesn't mean there's not a lot
going on behind the scenes and there's
definitely a storm brewing okay Sean
always good to see you thanks very much
indeed thank you